for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
so in the last video series we talked
about the wave particle duality of
matter and energy and how that was sort
of visa to quantum mechanics so
basically we have to accept the wave
particle duality of matter and energy so
that along with just the idea of
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle if
you combine those two concepts together
basically what you have is quantum
mechanics right so there's this guy or
wind Schrodinger and what he did was he
developed an equation that we'll see in
the next video that is the basis for the
quantum mechanical model the quantum
mechanical model of the atom the quantum
mechanical model of the atom which is an
atom where energy is quantized which of
course we've mentioned means that only
certain energy levels are allowed and an
electrons exact location is it possible
to know so that's kind of where the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle comes
in so series and is on the quantum
mechanical model and hope that video is
helpful introducing it thanks for
watching if you found that video helpful
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
and share with friends thank you and
happy studying